[Music]
DC Comics DC the city okay fine maybe
this city is perfectly lovely but DC
movies have such a bad reputation that
they forever ruined anything associated
with the initials like the band ac/dc
the actual direct current electricity
disco Cowboys and Las Vegas magicians
who made the Statue of Liberty disappear
these kind of streetlights are generally
staggered and not directly across from
each other so that they like different
sections of the rope come on DC why on
earth would you have two different Joker
movies I mean lights covering the same
ground no random bystander what are you
doing she screamed told you to get away
and starts putting her window up and you
decide to put your arm inside her
vehicle who does that guy jumps on top
of the car instead of to the side of it
as if he knows the driver is demon
hallucinating and why are all these
people just standing in the middle of
the road in the first place and not even
remotely trying to move out of the way
of the speeding car that they've
witnessed mow down many people prior why
does she see Wonder Woman normally did
Wonder Woman get some anti demonic
elucidation cream from Batman's
endlessly supplied utility belt I see
one harsh much clearly something dub is
going on with this woman who was begging
for double WS help and she lays it on
this thick Justice League so what have
you done I mean Superman just looked in
the shed right question seems a little
unnecessary also does the Justice League
dark moniker automatically mean all the
DC heroes have to speak like Batman not
my fault
in fairness I'm pretty sure I wouldn't
want to nurse baby eye mouth either
these crimes were committed by
law-abiding citizens camera caught this
footage even if he just happened to be
under a red light camera would get this
much of a close-up the one we got from
them for Jordan and it couldn't be some
hairy ass monster
how much Jon Stewart know that it's not
some hairy ass monster causing all this
Superman literally just said he had no
idea what the cost was also if we're
gonna pointlessly explain why Hal Jordan
isn't there then why not throw an
explanation for why Wonder Woman is
wearing this suit or why Hawkeye here at
all
are they implying David Copperfield
television magician has true power I'm
just wondering if they are implying that
David Copperfield was still relevant in
2017 you'll Rati soul ain't worth two
bits not two bits
I assume demon three of three here used
to watch The Karate Kid as a young demon
in hope that's
day he could be the get him a body bag
guy at the DC Universe I'm betting the
house the house of mystery how did these
demons know exactly where to look before
the house even materialized magical
poker shenanigans aside if both players
have the seven of diamonds then this is
a misdeal and Constantine wins nothing
technically we both cheated I just did
it better in what world is what
Constantine did cheating ponytail demon
magic the cards and Constantine just
unmagic them there is no way from that
angle that they don't see Constantine
crawl away unless the bar was the actual
target of the attack their continued
firewood free-for-all makes absolutely
no sense
so you'll sit in the shed unused and
then every once in a while you'll keep
his ass looking good by trimming away
the excess parts what a weird thing to
offer Batman needs to talk with John
you've got to come along too it's
important what it Boston even have to
possess Batman to convey this
information so you can see him right
couldn't have just asked her directly
then about five years ago karma caught
up with him circus position it's the
magic of the house decided he wanted to
experience humanity and gave itself a
body except with no nipples or
reproductive parts because even though
this is rated R and the human body is
nothing to be ashamed of we wouldn't
want to offend the delicacies of the DC
comic book fan base but she does have a
bellybutton if that makes any sense
also does that basically make her vision
because heaven forbid DC and Marvel not
have duplicates of every goddamn thing
you exude pain your life is a patchwork
of blackness with no time for joy
apparently Batman gets the same YouTube
comments we do luckily one of
Constantine's lesser-known powers is to
see previous scenes from any movie he's
in boo Batman can't see them then how
does he know where they are to scare
them away I thought I felt a disturbance
in the force
hey you got your Star Wars in my DC
movie someday when Disney releases of
interest 12 the further adventures of
Buzz and Yoda of Star Wars Toy Story all
of this will feel very quaint
is it Tana and Batman the actual pitch
for this film how does this work
it's basically a magical shortcut well
at least you're admitting it but that
doesn't make it any less simple
ever liked this sort of magic and yet
just mere seconds ago you were begging
to MARY POPPINS yourself into this brain
painting make up your mind Z the magic I
perform brings people happiness
I'm sure the elephant trip was cute and
all but I'm pretty sure the low-cut tops
don't hinder happiness leave me alone
another precious moment there was joy to
his madness swept it away out of all the
movies I assume just asleep dark would
be ripping off inside out was not one of
them demon diarrhea I guess you gotta
use the cards you're dealt but do these
cops really think guns will stop this
demon great save by dead man here but
why does he stay in this body to chase
after the monster wouldn't unpossessed
him be faster and keep the guard safer
what do you think will set him off
my guess is the sodoku he's got two
nines in the same row so don't go humor
how did bats know this attack of the
killer diarrhea could be stopped by fire
wouldn't it make more sense to throw
some imodium at it or maybe a wheel with
cheese does he not have those things in
his utility belt oh just really hit the
fan he has to go over Boston Constantine
would be magical it's cinemasins also I
wasn't aware that the R rating on DC
animated films just meant more
intensified jokes that would make the
Hotel Transylvania franchise cringe
let's get the hell out of here grunting
Batman may actually be the best part of
this movie I'm removing a sin don't bat
me
Constantine bollocks this rounds name is
bollocks
Batman has a syringe filled with
adrenaline in his utility belt because
of course he fucking does the seal of a
few tricks if at all nay not everything
requires magic true story but since
that's been brought up are you telling
me between Zatanna John Constantine and
fucking dead man not one member of DC
Magic the Gathering knows how to bring
someone back from the dead for a little
QA if you try and summon Etrigan I'll
fill your lungs with bile before the
first verse is done savvy
nope not savvy unfortunately Johnny Depp
has ruined that word for the rest of
movie don't pursue Johnny and the boat
you wrote in on the single most powerful
conduit of evil in the history of the
world Auto playing video ads destiny
forged the dream stone with black magic
and his song dream stone mother boxes
tomato tomahto be it animated or
live-action DC likes to step and won't
flee disappoint its audience with this
tesseract desk bull if destiny has that
kind of power why not just lead with
that his horse would have one less
Achilles tendon sliced open if he had
freedom this what's up for trade then
destinies as good a slave would you slay
him in a box would you slay with Lucius
Fox
Jesus doctor Ettrick as much so Marylin
is part of the Arthurian DC and
transformers universe this magical gets
around late in it the house keeps my
valuables out of phase so they don't go
wandering off convenient storage
facility of evil magical items it's
convenient but still the timing of the
stones appearance and its power
indicates that it's somehow involved
with these crimes they don't call them
the greatest detective for nothing I
give you wizard an asshole
extraordinaire Felix Faust you know you
don't have to magic everything
Constantine sometimes you can just
communicate using words and such
coincidentally a wizard an asshole
extraordinaire is what I have on my
business card actually it says I'm
wizard an asshole extraordinaire bitch
because I love the social network it's a
favorite hidey hole of one Alec Holland
whose corpse was taken to be the most
recent avatar of the green I have no
clue what any of this means but if
there's an avatar and of green gables
crossover film that I didn't know about
I wanted inside me now oh the old match
that turns into a floating platform
trick huh the nice thing about having
magic as your superpower is that you can
literally do anything and just write it
off a supernatural why did that work
magic yeah
Konstantin you dare threaten the green
swamp thing might actually be the most
interesting and well developed character
in the DC Comics universe and he gets a
couple 80s movies and an even a TV show
and sixteenth build and a third-rate
animated movie Iommi no John Constantine
because he enrages me movie make sure to
let the audience know every five minutes
that John Constantine is a dick
boss lives in an observatory which is
invisible it's a place where dark magic
would infect the earth below it still
doesn't explain how Swamp Thing can get
you there any better than cetana Jason
blood dead man or Constantine except for
we got to make sure we get every
supernatural being that DC has ever
concocted into a 75-minute movie I will
take you there so you are no longer here
yes usually works this is not that
Justice League I was promised in the
title of this movie yes I know what's
the name of the comic and sure Batman's
been tagging along but other than very
brief cameos at the beginning I still
think this movie would be more
accurately described as the Justice
minor-league foe who destroys more of
the green and your kind swamp or is a
plot convenient truth he has if I would
stoop to brawling with a demon fight
others of y'all filthy kind wouldn't
conjuring demons to fight Africans still
be fighting at ricchan like what I've
done with the place no woman can speak
in my sanctum sanctorium I conjured it
just for you and of course men
everywhere toxic magic Lindy why is
Constantine choking up water when he was
only in the cube for 18 seconds you
can't hold your breath even 18 seconds
somewhere Tom Cruise is mocking you
mercilessly it's the TV dinner of
spell-casting dear man TV dinner is the
fast food of out-of-date convenience
based metaphors dear ooh did you see how
magic cetana magic the pet magical magic
with her magic magic magic magic I'm
adding 50 sins for all the goddamn magic
magic in this movie magic I understand
we're supposed to be getting all
emotional about her willpower to not
kill Faust and all but he's still a
fully powered magical badass and you
just turn away for an old time cuddle
cry stay in the game Constantine see now
you were told to do everything to help
me by the master of the house and that
does not include punching okay fine but
when he said i order you to help him any
in every way you're able it was right
after he said keep him alive and safe
understand though I'm pretty sure
contextually that once he's shown such
tendencies towards evil you are free to
commence with the purple punching
that leads you out of my hair for now so
why don't you just go for a little walk
I would orchid take this to me and she
needed to walk into the fire Ricci just
said go for a walk she could have
literally walked anywhere but if as
constantine explained earlier the house
phases every item so no one can just
take them how is Ricci doing just that
granted Ricci might have the power to do
this but call if the movies gonna help
us understand how that's possible they
don't call him the greatest detective
from nothing we had to frame Faust and
get you to bring me here ignoring the
fact that this entire movie's plot is
all the result of a terribly played hand
of Poker Ritchie's plan has a lot of
holes how did he know Constantine would
need to sell and how did he know Johnny
would bring him back to the house after
reviving it well the only reason Ritchie
was even still alive is because a Batman
who he had no way of knowing would get
involved also does this mean Ritchie
sent all those demon hallucinations out
to attract attention and if so why use
them in the places that the Justice
League would get involved if he only
needed Johnny's assistance then why not
go to somewhere that would get
Constantine invested Deadman doesn't
paint Batman's walls Constantine might
never have been contacted the amount of
magic she's used sometimes you don't
look all that right because stepping
things and such they'll have this city
by midnight the eastern seaboard by dawn
then what's to stop it he'll be a god
that's all take over a city and some
change and you're declared a god 2017
god regulations are the lowest they've
been in centuries dead man in Star Trek
5 asking the important questions of our
deities the Justice League are on their
way with five minutes left in the movie
sounds about right but make sure they
stay well away from destiny to not be
struck mad unless you want a bunch of
crazed super blokes ripping apart the
city geez Constantine foreshadow much
it's not just that we don't need to know
that information it's that when it
actually happens the story would have
been better if we weren't expecting it
or had figured it out ourselves
if cetana had only been in a DC board
room a few years ago she could have
saved us all a lot of trouble and she
wouldn't have even had to mention that
name well good
- super entities with undefined supreme
powers hitting each other and throwing
each other around I feel like I'm
watching an alien sex tape I have no
idea what's really happening or how the
parts all work I'm not even sure I want
to stick around and find out who's on
top after the climax we could have a
tree with the Tuesday
no definitely not well let's muck that
is a maybe I haven't the foggiest what a
tree Whittle Tuesday is but I do know
that no means no Konstantine so you
better just get your tree whittled
somewhere else I recommend spending more
time on the streets instead of flying
over them once more with was of nature
Ron comes Etrigan the Slayer just inside
[Music]
when you burst in I knew I'd get blamed
so I ran
[Music]
get away you will pay constant Jane your
soul will be ours there was joy to his
madness swept it away
I will take you there so you are no
longer here then as a wise man once said
wherever you go there you are